das hier ist mein allererster Film im
weitesten Sinne des Wortes jedenfalls
ich bin neun Jahre alt und tu so als
würde ich gerade eine naturdoku drehen
über das Leben unserer Katze Balu und
den tiefsinnigen Gesprächen die Balu mit
der Gießkanne geführt hat was sagen sie
zu dieser Reportage
gefilmt habe ich das mit dem Handy
meiner Mom mit dem auch diese ersten
selfies von mir entstanden sind und
dieser allererste Stop Motion Film in
dem eine Lego Figur eine andere Box und
dann einfach sein Helm klaut und diese
Action Szene die euch das Blut in den
Adern gefrieren lässt
Jahre vergingen aber ich war hooked
spätestens seitdem ich mit 12 den alten
Laptop meiner Oma bekommen habe weil
jeder After Effects Effekte unsicher
denn nicht bei 3 auf dem Baum bauen als
ich dann mit 15 eine richtige Kamera
bekommen habe was ganz vorbei
mittlerweile mache ich ja weniger was
Kameras Musikvideos und visuelle effects
angeht sondern hauptsächlich diese
Youtube Videos und habe deshalb aus
zeitlichen Gründen obwohl es eigentlich
schon längst überfällig ist noch nie an
dem Film gearbeitet das ändern wir jetzt
und ich produziere einfach den eigenen
Film in einer Woche dieses Video wird
unterstützt von Parts mehr dazu später
jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage
was für eine Art Filme machen und beim
ersten Film ist das natürlich ein
Kurzfilm ein Kurzfilm ist in der Regel
maximal 15 Minuten lang und zeigt der
Filmbranche ob man das auf dem Kasten
hat und ob man eine Geschichte erzählen
kann und das ohne dass es 100.000 Euro
und mehrere Jahre braucht wie so ein
Spielfilm verschlingen würde um
herauszufinden ob mein Kurzfilm wirklich
auch was taugt werde ich ihn am Ende bei
einem Kurzfilmfestival einreichen gegen
die Kurzfilme von anderen antreten und
schauen ob ich gewinnen ich fange jetzt
einfach mal an mich mit Inspiration
berieseln zu lassen Bilder Musik und
warum nicht ist 2020 künstliche
Intelligenz preisgekrönter Kurzfilm okay
okay okay okay ja also wenn ich in die
KI jetzt eingeben ein Steampunk
Luftschiff in der Form eines Wales guckt
er mir zwar richtig geile Ergebnisse aus
hier hier hier oder hier auf Wunsch
sogar fotorealistisch aber die Idee muss
ich halt trotzdem selber noch haben und
ich glaube das Geld dafür ein Kurzfilm
also muss ich da jetzt durch was mir
immer hilft sind Einschränkungen immer
wenn ich von dem weißen Blatt stehe ist
mein Gehirn genauso leer wie das Papier
aber sobald deine Einschränkung steht
z.B Dinosaurier und Höhlenmensch hat
meine Fantasie irgendwie eine Welt in
die sie eintauchen kann genauso habe ich
auch gemacht
habe und jetzt beim Film ist das erste
was man den Sinn kommt
Zeitreisender dieses eine Wort hat
gereicht und das Konzept rieselt quasi
aus meinen Fingern durch die Tastatur
hindurch auf den Bildschirm ein
Wissenschaftler bastelt um das Jahr 1890
an einem Gerät er schaut auf seine
Taschenuhr es wird gerade punkt 12 Uhr
und notiert sich die Zeit er werkelt an
dem Gerät drückt einen Knopf und zack
der Wissenschaftler erwacht wie aus
einem Traum er schaut erneut auf die Uhr
es schlägt erneut Punkt 12 die
Zeitmaschine ist erfunden alle Zeitungen
berichten in einem radiogespräch stellt
sich heraus dass bisher nur winzige
Sprünge in die Vergangenheit möglich
sind mehr wäre viel zu riskant der
Radiosprecher ist enttäuscht und wir
haben von der Zukunft und steckt mit
seiner Begeisterung den Wissenschaftler
an der Wissenschaftler verlässt das
radiohaus und geht nachdenklich nach
Hause schaut aus dem Fenster und
zeichnet sich die Zukunft wie er sie
sich vorstellt mit Feder auf Papier
erfasst sich einen Ruck und riskiert die
Reise in ferne Zeiten geil ich finde es
gut ist überhaupt nicht leicht
umzusetzen aber ich finde es gut das
heißt ich brauche jetzt jemanden mit
einer geilen Stimme also Radiosprecher
ich brauche einen Schauspieler weil ich
kann das überhaupt nicht und klar
Filmmusik bei euch auch noch und da
Arbeitsplatz ins Spiel passt es eine
Plattform auf der kreative Filme Macher
Regisseure Kameraleute lichtleute
Schauspieler Katha und alles drumherum
entweder selbst gefunden werden können
oder auch andere kreative finden können
mit denen sie Revision umsetzen können
man kann hier bei der Anmeldung auch
schon einstellen ob man entweder bezahlt
werden will das ganze ehrenamtlich macht
oder eben ob man es macht um einfach
Erfahrungen und Referenzen für sein
Portfolio zu sammeln ich erstelle mir
gerade neues Projekt und nennst einfach
mal Zeitreise Kurzfilm und um Leute zu
finden die haben für mitwirken erstelle
ich jetzt einen neuen Beitrag und
schreibt hi wir suchen für einen
Kurzfilm drehen München noch eine Crew
und jetzt mal Infos drin sind gehe ich
auf posten die über 9000 Nutzer von
Parts sind jetzt genau diesen Beitrag
und können sich bei mir melden dann kann
aber auch mit verschiedenen Filtern
Leute suchen und die direkt anschreiben
und das mache ich jetzt auch noch und
dann schauen wir einfach morgen noch mal
rein also 13 Antworten Tom westfroren
also allerdings als Sprecher angefragt
habe schreibt halt Thomas dass wir klar
mache ich gern wo kommt er her suche
immer mal wieder Fotografen Kameramänner
für Demoaufnahmen München da werde ich
zufällig bei dir sein cool also das
heißt ich habe direkt eben jetzt quasi
genetwork und direkt suchen auch noch
Kontakten das ist echt cool das heißt
hier hat man schon jemanden der Sprecher
sein könnte ich hoffe wirklich dass auf
dem Schauspieler dabei ist ah das ist
jetzt jemand dem ich nicht direkt
geschrieben habe sondern der hat einfach
meine Anzeige gesehen an bei meinem
demorill ja let's go ich höre ich mal
rein das Ziel ist lokalisiert
Eingang auf 2 Uhr ist ja geil ich glaube
wir könnten gut sprechen sein Birgit
Werner Werner Haupt und Nebenrolle
interessiert sehr cool hat keine
Webseite geschickt krass auch das halt
so viel Energie Umgebung hier sind cool
der Silas angeschrieben weil ich gerne
Musik hätte von ihm für einen Film also
frag mich jetzt wie lange kurz geht
fahren wir zwei bis vier Minuten das ist
von diesem Musiker
[Musik]
der Robert braun auch als Radiosprecher
okay krass also sogar schon Sachen für
Lidl gemacht und ZDF crazy sind auch
Leute dabei sehr gut sehr gut danke
gleich direkt einen Preis mitgeschickt
geht auch super viele Videos einfach
kostenlos machen einfach nur um
Referenzen zu kriegen für das Portfolio
oder einfach den Kontakt zu knüpfen ich
persönlich da ich halt hier generell mit
youtube geld verdienen habe natürlich
nicht unbedingt Lust da Leute für mich
umsonst arbeiten zu lassen wir haben
schon eine Bewerbung auf die Hauptrolle
oder hat natürlich auch so ein Clips wie
sich schauspielert was natürlich auch
super spannend ist weil Schauspieler
schwierig es ist einfach super schwierig
ich konnte überhaupt nicht ich kann es
auch überhaupt nicht okay schauen wir
mal
der Typ hat in die Disco geschossen
am besten an wenn er schon ein paar
Szenen gedreht habt oder und wie soll es
ein Bild erwischt ich sitze hier am
Skript und komme tatsächlich einmal
nicht weiter ich bin gerade bei der
Stelle oder Wissenschaftler gerade in
die Gegend war da sind die heutige
Gegenwart kommt und generell habe ich
noch nicht so eine richtige Idee wo die
Story dann eigentlich hingehen soll
deswegen düse ich jetzt einfach mal nach
München rein und schauen wir die Stadt
an da werde ich bestimmt ein paar
bessere Ideen haben und mich besser in
die Welt rein fühlen können also wenn
ich jetzt hier das von Sofa ausmacht
so schön den E-Auto Audi Parkplatz
abgestaubt wir sind sehr Shoppingmeile
ich würde sagen let's go fancy schmelzi
wo hier wird sich jemand aus der Zukunft
denken Leute was machen die denn hier
vor allem bei dem Preisen
[Musik]
es gibt natürlich super viele alte
Gebäude das praktisch ist weil genau
hier könnte ich mir so eine coole
Verkündung vorstellen wo hier so die
neue Erfindung vorgestellt wird und dann
hier so Fotos und Zeitungsartikel ich
glaube das kann man sehr gut hier
umsetzen ich habe jetzt heute also am
Montag am Wochenende noch mal angeschaut
und es hat einfach jeder gerne ich habe
hier überall zack zack zack antworten
muss ich heute melden ja den Cars
natürlich jetzt schon fast voll aber
hier hat sie noch meine Schauspielerin
gemeldet noch mal jemand für Musik und
auch ein Video Graf also jemand der
quasi Kamera machen würde wir kommen
jetzt hier gerade einen Komponisten weil
der braucht natürlich auch schon mal
irgendwas vom Film um da Musik zu machen
es gibt allerdings noch keinen Film du
musst dich dafür jetzt erstmal eine
Storyboard für die erste Szene fertig
machen damit er überhaupt irgendein
Anhaltspunkt hat ich bin Silas und ich
habe den Soundtrack für Thomas Film
komponiert was mir wirklich sehr viel
Freude gemacht hat auch wenn wir ein
bisschen unkonventionell
zusammengearbeitet haben ich habe
nämlich nicht in originalen Film am
Anfang sondern nur so KI erstellte
Bilder die ein bisschen verstörend waren
ich habe mir am Anfang gedacht es geht
um das Thema Zeit deswegen fange ich mit
einem Uhren ticken an was auch so von
rechts nach links geht und zu zeigen wie
dynamisch die Zeit eben ist und es geht
ja auch um die Reise in die
Vergangenheit deswegen habe ich immer
wieder mit reverse Sound also
umgekehrten Sounds gearbeitet
hier ein Klavier was rückwärts
abgespielt wird und dann eben auch
wieder vorwärts und dann geht's eben in
den
kompletten Soundtrack über
ist dieses Thema was ich immer wieder
durchzieht genau ja hat viel viel Freude
gemacht danke Thomas für die Erfahrung
absolut genial aber mehr dazu später
weil eigentlich muss ja erstmal der Film
fertig gemacht werden ich muss nur geben
ich bin gerade hart gestresstes maximal
dumm in einer Vergangenheit spielt ich
brauche jetzt eine Location die in der
Vergangenheit passt ich brauche ein
Kostüm das für die Vergangenheit passt
idealerweise hat bis morgen alles
ey das ist so stressig und komplett
außerhalb meiner Komfortzone so wir sind
jetzt wieder München und jetzt geht's
auf zu Bavaria Film Platz irgendwas weil
da gibt's Filme Requisiten
so jetzt ganz viel Zeug drin Auto ist
voll jetzt holen wir kurz Manu ab der
die Kamera für dieses Video macht damit
ich quasi filmen kann für Kurzfilm dann
geht's ab zur Location die hat jetzt
auch noch irgendwie geklappt wir sind
quasi bei meinem Onkel in der Scheune
und jetzt treffe ich gleich die
Schauspielerin
jetzt geht's los es ist ein bisschen
spät aber wir kriegen das irgendwie hin
irgendwie haben wir am Ende von dieser
Woche in kurzfrist wir sind jetzt alle
Location es ist richtig geil es ist
einfach eine richtig alte Scheune
generell ist das Teil hier absolut als
wir bauen jetzt ein bisschen auf und
dann wird die ersten Szene gedreht
ist ein trinkrohr
wie so Esel
[Musik]
und bitte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mit einer Bewegung was zu und dann jetzt
einschalten
und bitte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so und dann Zeitsprung und dann war das
halt ein kurzer Sprung oder am anderen
drehst du halt komplett
lang und bitte
[Musik]
dann würde ich so machen dass du jetzt
erst so
zu drei Kobler macht und dann
gibt es noch richtig Gas und ist okay ne
also hier keine Ahnung so 50 Jahre also
okay ach scheiße auf direkt hier
[Musik]
ich hätte nicht gedacht aber ich glaube
das wird echt richtig cool wirklich toll
wir sind jetzt fertig
aber ich glaube ich würde auf jeden Fall
noch von der Lampe machen dafür die habe
ich nicht bezahlt
geil nachdem der erste Drehtag
erfolgreich im Kasten war geht es am Tag
drauf in die Innenstadt vor einem alten
Gebäude der Bayerischen Staatsoper
schießen wir ein Foto für einen
Zeitungsartikel im Film okay stolze
schaumig
perfekt voll cool und bitte im Anschluss
an die Fotos drehen wir Szenen in denen
die Wissenschaftlerinnen nach Hause geht
die ich mittlerweile übrigens Frau Dr
Krämer getauft haben
er ist arg frech das Fahrrad von da noch
da drüben zu stellen nö
und bitte
[Musik]
gar nicht so leicht
freust Dich gehabt so du schaust
vielleicht erstmal so auf deine Hände an
und schaust du nach vorne und dann
siehst Du halt die moderne und dann
setzen Blick ich weiß ich kann zu den
setzen Blick als wäre deine gelbe
Monetarisierung beim Video und bitte
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es auch direkt an den
Schnitt was besonders geil ist wir sehen
jetzt als allererstes mal diese ganzen
Schutz die wir gemacht haben genau hier
die Kamerafahrt links rechts ich finde
das super nice es sieht einfach
sieht so gut aus als die Lampe die ich
mit einer kompliziert habe wie ich
deswegen nur extra abgefilmt habe weil
ich dafür Geld bezahlt habe bei jedem
shot da ist eigentlich der ganze die
ganze Aufnahme gut sondern immer nur so
ein kleiner Ausschnitt den Ausschnitt
sieht mir jetzt raus in die Timeline
rein
[Musik]
so wir gehen auf paz.de denn ich vermute
und ich habe auch damit recht das ist
jetzt hier eine gute Tom Westbahn schon
hier haben wir den Download Link
geschickt hat einmal auf alt getrennt
einmal komplett unbearbeitet den Ton
okay ich bin gespannt ich habe einfach
mal direkt die bearbeitete Version an
Frau Dr Krämer in welches Jahr zu reisen
gedenken sie mit ihrer Erfindung zuerst
geil das nehmen wir direkt so und damit
gehe ich jetzt gleich in den Call mit
der guten Birgit und dann macht sie
quasi den Antwort Part drauf in welches
Jahr zu reisen gedenken sie mit ihrer
Erfindung zuerst von Jahren kann ich die
Rede sein handelt es sich doch um alles
so höchst komplexe Technologie Frau Dr
Krämer vielen Dank
schick mir gerne Datei dann höre ich
noch mal mit meinem Kopfhörern an sehr
gut finde ich sehr gut super super
perfekt danke dir morgen muss er
Kurzfilm fertig werden übrigens und
jetzt liegt es eigentlich nur noch im
Schnitt
bin gerade letzten Zügen ist es mega
geil wie gerade alles zusammen kommt
Musik und Schnitt und die Stimmen es ist
richtig cool für den Teil mit dem
Zeitungsartikel muss ich jetzt noch ein
Foto photoshoppen weil ich beim
Fotoshoot die Zeitmaschine vergessen
habe blöd das Foto wird dann eingepflegt
in einen alten Zeitungsartikel dann
natürlich noch die Credits abspannen
also Text schreiben wir rein Frau Dr
Krämer Birgit Werner schönere Schriftart
irgendwas altes als Radiosprecher der
muss jetzt leider schummeln und nochmals
genau schauen er ist Tom platz.de genau
und zwar Tom westborn so Musik der gute
Johannes Silas
mega geil gewesen wirklich und dann
komme ich also was bin ich Regie und
Produktion und Kamera eigentlich und
Schnitt wie bei einer Gruppenarbeit wenn
man so alles gemacht ist so Regie
Schnitt Kamera Lichtsetzung Drehbuch
habe ich auch Autor refiziert und das
mache ich jetzt wie folgt dass sie jetzt
mal lange und so diese einzelnen Sachen
nicht gemacht
und schnitt
ja finde ich nice finde ich nice komm zu
lassen sehr wohl und schon ist der Film
fertig den ich innerhalb von einer Woche
gemacht habe zusammen mit meiner Crew
die ich auf Paz unter den über 9000
Nutzern gefunden habe über die
Projektseite kann man bei Party übrigens
nachdem man seine Crew gefunden und
eingeladen hat auch Termine wie z.B
Drehtage und To-Dos wie z.B
locationscouting erstellen wodurch Parts
perfekt ist und kostenlos seine
Produktion zu organisieren und jetzt
viel Spaß mit meinem Werk dass ich
genannt habe 12 Uhr Mittag Film ab
[Musik]
die Zeit sie werden es nicht glauben
Wissenschaftlerin hat Zeitmaschine
erfunden so verlauten es an diesem Tage
alle Gazetten sie ist heute zu Gast hier
im Funkhaus Frau Dr Krämer in welches
Jahr zu reisen gedenken sie mit ihrer
Erfindung zuerst in welches Jahr werte
Herr von Jahren kann ich die Rede sein
handelt es sich doch um eine so höchst
komplexe Technologie getestet wurden
bisher wenige Sekunden ausschließlich in
die Vergangenheit versteht sich aber
Frau Doktor können Sie Ihre Bedenken
erläutern nun ja bereits wenige Minuten
könnten schlimmste Komplikationen mit
sich führen in die Vergangenheit wohl
bemerkt Sprünge gar in die Zukunft
dann mag sich nicht ausmalen welche
zeitlichen und räumlichen Verflechtungen
entstünden würde man nicht zuvor
sämtliche Ungewissheiten auszählen ein
Prozess ja nun Versprechen nicht von
Jahrzehnten aber reizt es Sie nicht zu
blicken in die ferne Zeit zu erfahren
welch Wunder die Zukunft welche Wunder
der Fortschritt bringt brennt das Herz
eines jeden Wissenschaftlers nicht dafür
die Ergebnisse seines Schaffens ihre
Maschine vollends auszureizen natürlich
zu sehen welche Städte erbaut welche
Geschichten geteilt und weil ich Lieder
gesungen werden dennoch ausgeschlossen
Disziplin ist angesagt Frau Dr Krämer
vielen Dank bitte sehr Reisen in die
Zukunft bleibt Zukunftsmusik und Musik
ist das korrekte Stichwort es geht
weiter im Programm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich finde es geil ich hatte da echt
Angst dass ich den ganzen innerhalb von
einer Woche überhaupt nicht gerecht
werden kann aber ich finde wir als Crew
haben da was richtig geiles auf die
Beine gestellt beim Kurzfilmfestival
habe ich den Film dann sogar im Kino auf
der großen Leinwand gesehen und mit dem
Film den dritten Platz geholt wenn ihr
jetzt auch Lust auf dem Filmfest
bekommen habt da habe ich einen Tipp für
euch Parts veranstaltet am 15.10 ein
eigenes das patz-filmfest in Berlin der
Link zu Platz der kostenlosen Plattform
für Newcomer im Filmbereich ist in der
Beschreibung ich fand es extrem geil wie
einfach es damit ist mit komplett
fremden Kontakt zu treten und mit denen
seine Vision umzusetzen wenn ihr
außerdem an einer Filmförderung von bis
zu 5000 Euro interessiert seid check mal
passt die / Booster ab ich hoffe mein
Film hat euch gefallen und ich bin damit
raus